hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Aled Jones Kevin McGuire and Andrew
Pierce are here to look back at the
biggest stories of the past seven days
so gentlemen what were your top stories
of the week then the horrific terrorist
incident in Paris in France where the
priest was murdered just appalling I
think it's going to be Hillary Clinton
break and a glass ceiling in the US by
being the first woman nominated for
president by one of the major political
parties but of course more on both of
those stories in just a second first
let's get a taste of what the week was
all about terrorism tainted Europe again
this week with the murder of a French
priest by two young sympathizers of
so-called Islamic state Germany was also
on alert following a suicide bombing in
a town in Bavaria which injured more
than a dozen people in Japan 19 people
were stabbed to death at a center for
the disabled in the country's worst mass
killing for more than half a century a
man accused of carrying out the attack
is a former employee at the center
Hillary Clinton formally accepted at the
Democratic presidential nomination
Labor's own leadership race experience
another twist as the High Court threw
out an attempt to stop Jeremy Corbyn
being automatically included on the
ballot French firm EDF voted to build
Britain's first new nuclear power
station for a generation for the
government put the brakes on the plan
until the autumn office workers were
told to get active with recommendations
of an hour's exercise a day for those
who work sitting down and a tourist
guide in Bolivia has found what's
believed to be one of the biggest
dinosaur footprints ever found it's
thought to have been left by the
meat-eating Allosaurus some 80 million
years ago
so a really busy week then at what stood
out for you amongst all of that hinkley
point I think it's a disastrous decision
to go ahead with it should the
government and I believe it only pause
because it's 18 billion but you're
getting a state-run French company a
state-run Chinese company try and keep
the lights on here you need a 30 billion
subsidy over the period lot right it's
not mean high electricity prices the
Tories and labour made a huge mistake by
dismantling our own nuclear industry we
should rebuild it up and then construct
our own power stations the electricity
will be sold to British householders at
three times the current rate which is
outrageous so I'm hoping now we've got a
new government they're going to take a
whole look at that it's a few other big
infrastructure projects they could think
about to hs2 while we're on the case but
actually it's too expensive and I don't
think British people want their energy
controlled by the Chinese okay well
let's move on now because France and
Germany both suffered terror attacks
this week a suicide bomber injured 15
people in the german town of Anne's back
and then on Tuesday two teenagers
murdered a priest in France before being
shot dead by police well from Santa
DeAnda Ruth way skies Nick Martin
reports France is in mourning once again
but it's also being drawn deeper into
war in Santa tienda roof ray they are
numb with shock their priests murdered
in his own church by so-called soldiers
from the Islamic state police were
initially called to an apparent hostage
situation in the town just outside the
Normandy city of Rouen armed police were
fast on the scene the two attackers both
with knives had entered through a back
door during morning Mass father Jacques
ml a Roman Catholic priest was Tolton
kneel before the altar before he was
murdered terror on French soil once
again one of the attackers has been
identified as 19 year old Adele commish
this is him as an 11 year old at a
school in Santa tienda
roof ray he was well known and liked by
many who knew him he was such a nice lad
honestly I used to really get on well
with him he was actually quite funny I'd
never have imagined he could do this
well feel similar to me buddy tennisia
my son was in his class and he never
spoke about him there was never any need
for any suspicions about him nothing was
ever said but some say he didn't hide
his feelings about wanting to travel to
Syria in it Zig work before he told us
you had to go there to fight for our
brothers we would tell him that's not
okay then he would say France is the
land of miscreants you shouldn't live
here that's how he tried to indoctrinate
us but we didn't care what he was saying
but French authorities have revealed
they knew a lot about kermis and his
attempts to flee to Syria as this town
works out what could have gone so badly
wrong with one of their own the security
services now are on high alert and of
course any loss of life is is a tragedy
but the symbolism of this killing of an
elderly priest inside a church is called
real shock in France isn't you think you
can't be shocked anymore but this was so
profoundly shocking and brutal and
sacrilegious and all that sort of stuff
really really appalling and I'm afraid
it's another terrible failure by the
French security so it's intended one of
those two boys was wearing a tag and it
was switched off they knew all about him
and his parents had been into the police
just a couple of weeks before saying but
God's sake lock him up because he's
going to try and kill someone and they
didn't both known to the security
services and it's a real challenge for
politicians as well isn't it to try to
make sure that the country is unified I
mean there's a danger of a backlash
after attacks like this that's right it
started because it's I think it's 14
terror attacks now in france in two
years more than 240 people killed and
that solidarity you've got after Charlie
Hebdo and the attack on the Jewish
restaurant and then the back on since
nice and now this it's turning to real
anger and frustration and politicians
really don't have simple answers because
they don't exist but you need to keep
that solidarity as far as you can
and as part the answer is security and
the rest is political and in the
communities okay let's move on now
because it is now time for our gap of
the week and the boss of the British
Council responsible for protein Britain
around the world is facing an
investigation for criticizing Prince
George Angela Gibbons went on a rant on
Facebook suggesting that the royal
family have no place in a modern
democracy and that their privilege
needed to end well she's now being
investigated by her employers but do you
think that's fair she's allowed to
express her she's an idiot she was
referring to a three year old boy
talking about how you can already see
the privilege in his cheekbones
effectively calling him a parasite the
British camps is all about promoting
Britain abroad actually the royal family
one of the reasons people come to
Britain they like to see the pump and
the pageantry in the palaces it's deeply
offensive and actually who pays half of
her salary the British taxpayer she's in
as much shock to us the taxpayer as the
royal family and actually don't forget
actually Prince William's money comes
from the Duchy of Cornwall by his father
well I thought what she said was
unpleasant cuz a three-year-old boy you
can't say in his cheeky grin innately he
knows he's gonna have a lie supply for
privilege he will but at the same time I
did find that the lynch mob that went
against her as unpleasant if not more so
because just because you employed
somewhere it doesn't mean you can't have
a view she's the estates manager she's
in charge of offices she's not going
around the world publicly speaking but
if you're if you're a nurse you're a
teacher you're a civil servant you work
for a local council you can work for the
fire service you can still have views
and the same applies to the British
Council okay well we'll leave that there
but don't forget you can send us your
nominations for gap of the week using
hashtag W in our I'm sure you've got
lots of suggestions now then this week
Hillary Clinton became the first woman
to accept the presidential nomination of
a major American party in a speech in
Philadelphia she took aim at her rival
Donald Trump and warned voters against
messages of fear Donald Trump says and
this is a quote I know more about Isis
then the generals do
no Donald you don't imagine him in the
Oval Office facing a real crisis a man
you can bait with a tweet is not a man
we can trust with nuclear weapons yes
the world is watching what we do yes
America's destiny is ours to choose so
let's be stronger together my fellow
American
to the future with courage and
confidence let's build a better tomorrow
for our beloved children and our beloved
country and when we do America will be
greater than ever so how do you think
she did I thought she did really well
much better than I thought she wouldn't
she had hope and optimism in her appeal
while Trump was all about hate and
division I think she absolutely knocked
him out of the park and I'm surprised
you did the it's interesting cuz when
2008 when she didn't be a barman
everybody thought she was gonna walk if
she said she'd removed some large chunks
from the grass ceiling and now of course
she shattered it completely because she
is of course the first woman to be
nominated as a candidate of one of the
two major parties to run for president
and all week lot was made of her
experience yes which is extraordinary if
you know restaurant each day and yet to
some extent that could count against her
because a lot of people see the appeal
of Donald Trump being the fact that he's
not of the establishment she has a
record she has to defend while he can
just attack attack attack and he doesn't
he doesn't have he hasn't made those
mistakes in office what a great line
about a man you can be it with a tweet
isn't a man you can trust when you can a
weapons when you will be the
commander-in-chief and it's quite right
about trump he's a reality TV show we
inherited a load of cash it had probably
made more money just leaving it in the
bank instead of having these property
empire but he goes around trying to stir
up racism and hatreds and to get the
white falk angry to get him in the in
the white house and he's not married to
a sleazebag unlike Hillary Clinton who
is now and Bill Clinton is it is will
drag as many votes away from her if not
more than he'll bring that I think he's
third wife just steals other people's
speeches and then invents degree she
hasn't got ya okay well let's talk about
Donald Trump because as the Democrats
were gathered rather in Philadelphia at
clintons Republican rival Donald Trump
made arguably his most bizarre comment
of the campaign yet Russia if you're
listening I hope you're able to find the
30,000 emails that are missing I think
you will probably be rewarded mitel
by our press so what do you make of that
I mean a summer called Donald Trump a
threat to national security others
accuse him of trees and there what do
you make of those comments he would have
accused Hillary Clinton of being a
traitor and treason if she said the same
and encouraging another country of cyber
espionage is rather extraordinary when
you want to be the commander-in-chief
now I mean moscow's sent it will be very
pleased that they've got a voluntary
agent the FSB they're advocating hacking
that's quite serious i know it's later
on so he was being sarcastic was it he
always does that but the truth is the
bloke is unhinged what he did and he did
it very successfully upstate the
Democratic convention entirely yet again
because he's very good at that and he's
reminded people that Hillary Clinton was
using a private email and she was set to
estate and she shouldn't have been it
was in breach of all the rules and tens
of thousands of those emails have gone
missing why so he could then say crooked
Hillary is reminded people he'd be
unsuitable as president it's time for
quiz of the week so can you tell me why
the skies could soon be busier I often
ask our banking I'll can you will get on
Andrew a break to know I think I know
both know already we can have their work
anywhere more financially welcome back
to we can review with me anna jones i'm
joined by kevin maguire associate editor
of The Daily Mirror and Andrew Pierce
consultant editor of The Daily Mail and
before the break I posed you the
question of why the skies could soon be
busier and you both had an answer well
I'm hazarding a guess that the
government has given the go-ahead to the
expansion of City Airport down in them
London that wasn't our uh I think
because amazon has been licensed to fly
drones as an experiment delivery pots if
they do i hope they're well paid
operators on a trade union so yes the
correct answer it's because the air
could soon be full of your online
purchases amazon have been given
permission to trial drones which could
deliver small parcels just a short time
after you place your order it'll be a
while before the service gets going
though so you won't have to duck to
avoid a flying DVD and
earth won't have to dodge books just yet
so let's move on there was relief for
Jeremy Corbyn as a legal challenge to
his automatic right to be included on
the Labour leadership ballot was
rejected by the high court while his
rival for the job Owen Smith launched
his campaign with some rather impactful
words we didn't have the strength and
the power and the vitality to smash her
back on her heels are you standing by
your comments saying that you want to
smash trees may back on her heels they
love a bit of rhetoric don't they we a
bit more robust rhetoric in our politics
I'm very much in favor of that you'll be
getting that from me and I absolutely
stand by those comets its rhetoric of
course I don't literally want to smash
Theresa May back just to be clear I'm
not advocating violence in any way shape
or form but I am rhetorically safe come
on smash the Tories back knock them on
their heels their ideas their values
let's smash them let's get labor in
that's what we need to do so do you
think there was anything wrong with Owen
Smith's language there I think he
admitted himself it was it could have
chosen his words better just because of
that image of possible violence but it
is a bit rugby club talk Italy a smash
and opponent back she often talks about
her own heels made him famous but it was
a shame for him about the stumble
overshadowed his policy launch because
he was trying to be more Corbin Easter
than Jeremy Corbyn with these proposals
on wages and health service and
important story had said that their
labour sister it would have swept into
full protest mode they'd have been
demanding resignations and and yet he
thought it was okay to try and say it
was the remote was justified and that
room of Labour Party supporters
chuckling and laughing along after the
fight I think the find the Labour sister
who did pick him up on it right right
did they do it was making was that it's
you need a more combat avapro chance the
Tories I'm do you don't need to deploy
such overtly sexist language
particularly when Jeremy Corbyn has got
a number of women MPs complain that
project Corbin is being overtly sexist
and aggressive to them and Jeremy Corbyn
will be on that
he will be part of the election campaign
so can anything stop him unlikely but
it's not impossible and he was quite
right Jeremy Corbyn that the legal
action by a donor clearly got too much
money was it was a waste of time and
resources although Jeremy Corbyn was
threatening his own legal action should
the decision of the Labour Party have
gone the other way and he was off the
ballot but the truth is like it Labour's
a political party this should be a
political argument settled by by debate
and the judge and jury should be the
members normally the British people in
an election not a High Court judge okay
we're going to move on to newspapers now
and what were your stories of the week
let's start with you Andrew shall we
well the MPs who investigated sir philip
green's shameful giving away of BHS have
published their report and they have
used that expression that Ted Heath
famous to use in the early 1970s about
Laura that he is the unacceptable fate
of capitalism and they really not pulled
their punches this select committee of
MPs because often they do and they've
effectively said if he doesn't restore
that 571 million deficit in the pension
fund remember when you took over BHS in
two thousand it was in a healthy
surplice he's lying his own pocket to
the some say as much as emit a billion
pounds from bjs not illegal but it would
be some would say inappropriate when the
pension fund is such a bad way and these
mp's is saying unless he does the right
thing by the Pentagon strip him of his
knighthood and he is saying that he's
looking into the issue and seeing what
he can do he hasn't hasn't been resolved
yet has it but what you think about
ignited in his wife a worth of her three
billion quid between them three yacht is
in fine 571 million quid like that you
made a fortune out of BHS and the good
days you can't just give it away for a
quid and walk away and look at I thought
it was ridiculous giving them a
knighthood it's probably gonna go it
should go and let's just stop awarding
them to tycoons while I we're doing that
wouldn't people who do public good met
people who are making a lot of money and
just to say as well the pension
protection plan will step in here to to
make up some of the deficit but who pays
for that everybody else is painful so
everybody watching this who's got a
pension they will be contributing well
because of the recklessness exactly the
final final salary pension fund you yeah
okay let's move on what's your what's
your first paper choice then
cats got me Lloyd's Lloyds Bank part
publicly owned includes the bank of
scotland and halifax 3000 job cuts
accelerating branch closures and
chugging some more in it just reported
baking two and a half billion in six
months it doubled its profits like its
its corporate greed this they're putting
shareholders no doubt the bonuses of
those at the top ahead of customers and
snap now for you if we're using more
internet banking we're going in a
branches less you can see there's going
to be some changes but this just seems
to be totally reckless and greedy the
worst part apart from the fact more
people are going to lose their jobs they
attempted to blame it on uncertainty
over s leaving the European Union and
then they had to admit but then but not
even 24 hours actually this decision was
taken months before that the referendum
when they probably assumed that we were
going to stay in the year you and your
next paper choice Andrew I think is a
good news for farmers not necessarily
for laughs well this was a story that
took me completely by surprise because
British lamb can go back on sale in the
US early next year I thought why isn't
it on sale there then it's very good
British lamb Welsh lamb in particular is
very nice and it's backpack goes back to
BSE all the way back from 1989 so
finally it's going to be great boost for
farmers and you know they're always
complaining it things ain't good they're
going to be flogging their me over there
again the guy I think I like British
lamp particularly well schlump like you
but if it's taken 20 70 years to get
this ban lifted oh it looks it going to
take to get a post brexit trade deal
with the US and the 35 million quid this
market is worth is a fraction of the two
billion in farming subsidies that is
such a bad Lisa Anna everyone has to
have an attorney at that breaks it seven
times four million people 50 for it
reality in reality okay and now a time
for your choice of paper and a great
British success ah Chris Froome what a
brilliant athlete you you wait while you
wait ages for a British winner of the
Tour de France and then you get what
four in five years now since Bradley
Wiggins will it in 2012 Chris Rutten
froome's won it three times in four
absolutely XX action brilliant by Team
Sky who've shaken up and cycling tomato
so good for Britain but it what an
endurance feet because I think he did
something like was it 2,000 miles and
the
equivalent the climbs up the peaks as I
going up Everest nearly seven times and
why so what they could do is take the
knighthood off of horrible buccaneering
businessman is at they re i give it to
chris free but wouldn't people be happy
about that what he might well get one
you never know fantastic well thanks
very much d for taking us through your
papers want now what about your ups and
downs and andrew i think we're starting
with you this time we are because i'm
sending up the ice bucket challenge you
remember it from a couple of years ago
people all over the country we're
agreeing to be doused in ice cold water
it raised so much money apparently if it
was done for sponsorship it's made it
enabled major advances in research into
areas of brain and motor neurone disease
is so that's fantastic so people didn't
get just get wet and cold but they're
making a real difference what he doesn't
i think at the time it was called
slacktivism this idea of you Brit don't
really have to work very hard for it and
it was a lot of people accusing
celebrities of showing off in a sense
but in fact seems to have done some real
good i turned against it when the celebs
get involved because you know that POS
are pushing them forward and some good
publicity in it but the fact is a lot of
ordinary people had fun as they did it
and raise money what's wrong with that
really what enough you can have fun
raise money good course do you never
have requested to took a bucket of cold
water over kevin maguire and it refused
no sense of sport with a lot of money
wouldn't have anybody had asked me I'd
have agreed to do i dont even done it
over here all right I got to pee anyone
but to like if you're gonna do it we
could make some cash ever to live I
brought my bucket with me yeah it's done
it on the spot okay well we're gonna
send my rocket challenge up and who are
you sending down this week that is mrs
legarda the head of the IMF who had the
temerity to lecturers not once but twice
to stay in the European Union third by
her former friend George Osborne octo
suppose they've been on the phone much
to each other now and she is not a job
it's gotta be used to face criminal a
criminal court case over an allegation
of a payment of businessman some years
ago she disputes it but it's a pretty
embarrassing episode four that's right
it's a her handling of that
isn't it she's been accused of
negligence did I British politics isn't
clean French politics is so murky and I
know she's innocent until proven guilty
but nevertheless she's not the only one
with a big financial finger-point nother
okay well we're gonna say crits
christine lagarde down and so Kevin what
about you who use any of this week us us
cuz we're tall I think the average male
is now five ten average female is at 55
or up just over four inches in in a
hundred years overtaking the Americans
the Dutch are still the tallest about
six feet that's good segue podunks cuz
I'm above average cuz I'm i'm sick so
where are you sitting on your to cushion
I Lucas Jason on to touch the ocean can
you see to ocean to make them bigger I
think I'm 59 and a half I also you below
average yeah and Dutch men and we're
gonna leave up with the racial
stereotypes pi beta phi mention the and
it's jarrett the tallest women in the
world yeah Latvians happens yeah back of
the net okay oh is that is that a
football analogy yeah that listens on
very neatly teen who you're sending down
this week i am flat footballers pep
guardiola the new man city manager is
bandham eatin pizza and is making over
white players you know train with the
reserves including samir nasri who's a
very good french french player but now
he's it he just wants them to have
suppose basmati rice and organic salmon
or whatever and they exactly they that
these footballers who have paid hundreds
of thousands of pounds a week in some
cases need to be told that they've got
to eat healthy food so they can sustain
fitness on the pitch and it's not just
fitness para para knees its first be
good for injuries and sleep patterns as
well what a pizza what do you like to
use like a polis melt it but they'll say
no anyway I mean that they have
dietitians and all that there don't ya
okay well let's send down pizza guzzling
or eating can you guys little [ __ ] I'm
not sure it's not things on the healthy
food and footballers that's going down
fantastic stuff don't forget you can
send us your nominations for ups and
downs using the hashtag Week in Review
well that's it thank you for joining us
for our view of the week we'll be back
for more next week but for now it's
goodbye from them goodbye aye skipper
for me